oh you [ __ ] how'd you know that
okay we yeah we kept everyone alive
there's that ryan reynolds really was
wanted for this part no
you know the thing about chan which is i
think we're gonna see more and more of
he's amazing when he has very little
time on screen
[Music]
their full birthday do we know their
full birthday i have no idea i have zero
clue they're pretty good yay yeah
neither one got that middle name middle
name no idea sandra annette oh you
[ __ ] how'd you know that
how did you do that come on dog no you
did some research yeah you did your
hometown sarasota
nope
there was
fun
tampa table's one of them uh dc nope
arlington virginia arlington god what
did i no
their dressing room must-haves uh 90s
hip-hop and or candles 90s hip-hop was
right your music having your music yeah
favorite scene to film in lost city i
think it was the wig at the event coming
out
it was yeah right i'll go with that um
your favorite scene was in the bathtub
with the wine no
[Laughter]
they're eating the cheese no
what was it
their go-to activities between filming
scenes well it depends yeah well that's
what this was not fair because she
didn't have any extra curricular
activities because she was producing so
it was it was not my go-to activity was
finding more money for the budget
without getting solving all the problems
on the movie i think i think our go-to
when we had the time was just being with
the kids and since his daughter was
there and my kids were there just having
that time with the kids
and making memories yeah does that mean
we get a check yeah let's check it out
uh oh no we've talked about my favorite
movie cinema paradiso yep uh practical
magic
it's not my favorite movie but but uh
like it's yeah why not
favorite snack at craft service you
couldn't you weren't really you had
mangoes i wasn't eating mangoes you had
mango strips
maybe once one time i had mango strips
does not a favorite snack make i eat a
lot of junk when i'm filming it's like
there's like a pound of ice i've never
seen swedish fish so you know twisted
sweetest fish i've seen you eat yes but
you didn't he ate nothing because he was
in training so he had he had air their
favorite project
of yours oh is this where i can use
magical magic you liked my part in free
guy
[Music]
i don't know if you guys have seen free
guy he is
so effing funny ryan reynolds absolutely
brilliant ryan reynolds really was
wanted for this part and uh and one he
wasn't available and yeah available so
we got second best i got i got the
camera
you know the thing about
chan which is i think we're gonna see
more and more of he's amazing when he
has very little time on screen
i really shine people are going to want
to see him less and less on screen if
you give me an arc a full arc i'm
definitely going to ruin it and i'm
happy you can't give him a lot of things
to say either you have a parachute in
real quick and then get out before i
mess it up it's going to be i'm great
hidden talent uh sandra has this talent
it's like it's like a something comes
over her and she we call it tidbits it's
it's like she has the internet like in
her brain she'll all of a sudden just
like kind of switch into this like
information mode and she'll tell you
this and it's not really information
it's called tidbits for a reason it's a
little bit of something absolutely
unimportant i don't know if it's
important and not useful tell me when
any of my tidbits have served as any uh
your tidbits about like like science and
things um around like code and i'm sure
were helpful okay yeah we kept everyone
alive there's that he is an
extraordinary fine artist
he is a beautiful sculptor and artist
it's it's something i mean i don't know
how hidden it is anymore but i don't
think most people know that am i right i
i like heart
[Music]
i got seven out of ten really i think i
lost i just got five how did you get
seven i don't know i probably cheated
you you cheated a little bit let me see
what you just said
all right he wins even if i take out
favorite snack i still win he still wins
he's a winner go watch the film lost
city
oh my gosh i can't what is your middle
name matthew what what you do not look
like a matthew middle name cmt country
music television oh my god